[Music]
thank you
Dr Atia Peter nice to see you good to
see you man
I want to start with the personal we're
going to get into all sorts of topics
many different aspects of your practice
Lessons Learned Etc but I went to your
house recently we had some Topo Chico
and a bite to eat and a few other things
and I commented on how much larger you
were and not larger as in obese but
muscularly larger so I thought we would
begin with the question of how and why
not necessarily in that order you added
so much muscle mass
well in the the fall of 2021 I had sort
of hit
a relative low in weight that wasn't
quite as low as where I was as a cyclist
which was probably about 165 pounds but
it was still pretty low for me kind of
in the low to mid 170s and I did a dexa
scan which I do periodically probably a
couple times a year but I hadn't done
one in a few years and when I get my
dexa skins you know I always plot the
data right so I'm not just interested in
body fat but also you know bone mineral
content and many other metrics but one
of them that's really important is
something called appendicular lean mass
index or almi another one is called ffmi
fat-free mass index
and it's probably worth explaining a
little bit about what these are but the
almi takes what the dexa scan imputes as
the lean tissue in your arms and legs in
kilograms divides that by your height in
meters squared so it spits out a number
like eight kilograms per meter squared
this is a pretty accurate representation
of how much muscle you have in your arms
and legs because the dexa scan can
really only identify three things bone
fat and other
and since things in your arms that are
not bone and fat tend to be muscle it's
pretty good at identifying muscle
whereas the fat-free mass index looks at
the entire body and just subtracts out
fat that's also a good proxy for lean
mass but there are many other things
like organs that are taking up some
residents there
anyway when I looked at these metrics I
was shocked I was shocked at how much
less muscle I had than 10 years earlier
almost exactly 10 years sooner and you
know I attribute it to several things
but I really thought that Chief among
them was just how much fasting I had
been doing over the previous three years
you know I had really kind of Taken
fasting to a pretty extreme place
you know doing up to 10 days of water
only and routinely just busting out
seven day water only fasts certainly
doing three days every month would be
you know something I would do without
hesitation when you say 10 days of water
only over a period of time is that
meaning like how frequently would I do
that yeah I'm just wondering what the
Cadence was if we take it as a minimum
to be coming quarterly
got it yeah probably every quarter and
while I certainly think there are some
benefits from doing that I think what I
was sort of confronting was wow there's
actually a pretty big cost as well and I
would go out of my way while fasting to
still exercise I was lifting weights
every single day which was difficult
sometimes
but doing everything I could to sort of
try to stimulate muscle protein
synthesis but at the end of the day if
you're not providing any nutrients
including amino acids you're basically
just tearing down muscle to try to
rebuild with that muscle but your your
net effect is a loss so
I I just said like I got I gotta fix
this like I gotta do something about
this and I don't you know I want to have
my almib in the at least the 90th
percentile if not above the 97th
percentile as I age
the data are pretty unambiguous that
people live longer better lives with an
almi north of the 75th percentile
so you know not one to just clear the
bar I want to be considerably above the
bar
so basically I just changed things
around and said you know nutrition and
exercise are going to change a little
bit
so you know we can talk about those
changes but basically I made big changes
with with exercise and nutrition how
much lean mass did you gain over what
period of time
would you say what's making these
changes
so in a span of oh God I'd have to go
back and look at the exact data I
believe it was 13 or 14 pounds of lean
mass in about 12 months
which is again that's not Herculean
right like these are not insane numbers
not taking anabolic steroids this is you
know relatively doable for someone who
is making it
a high priority to eat the right amount
of protein the right kind of protein and
spacing it and consuming it at the right
times and then also focusing training on
a little more hypertrophy so for people
listening I'm asking these questions not
simply because I'm interested in lean
muscle mass but also the implications
for longevity so I'm guessing you did
not put all of that lean muscle on your
biceps and that there were other
movements that were Incorporated for
very particular reasons if I if I'm
getting my read on Dr Peter Tia right as
I think I am so perhaps you could just
describe some of those changes and also
protein and how you suggest people think
about protein how you began thinking
about protein
yeah I'll start with that and we can
talk about the training so the the
protein basically went to a very
conscious and concerted effort
to increase protein to one gram per
pound of body weight people are going to
ask is that one pound of actual body
weight is that one pound of lean body
weight is that one pound of Target body
weight the answer is for someone my size
and weight and my body fat percentage I
think at the time I was about 15 body
fat it really doesn't matter it could be
basically call it one pound of current
body weight one gram per pound of
current body weight is sufficient so
that's what I did
the next question though becomes timing
and this is something that right until a
couple years ago I wasn't really paying
enough attention to so it it wasn't
enough to just say well Peter you got to
have 180 grams of protein in a day
because for example two 90 gram boluses
of protein doesn't accomplish nearly the
same thing as four 45 gram servings
spread out over the course of a day so
there is kind of a sweet spot with
protein where
you really need to be north of about 20
to 25 grams to ensure that those amino
acids aren't just going into what's
called a gluconeogenic Pathways we can
turn protein into glucose but we don't
really want to
you know protein should be thought of as
a structural nutrient whereas we want to
really think of carbohydrates and fats
as energy nutrients
so you have to have enough protein in a
given serving that you don't just have
the liver take it and use its bit for
gluconeogenesis
at the same time you don't want to have
too much and too much is a bit of a
an unclear
limit but my best reading of the
literature is that you're starting to
hit too much at about 50 grams in a
serving and what type of protein are we
talking about just in terms of I'm
thinking of bioavailability and protein
efficiency ratio
how should people think about quality or
type of protein
so the first decision I think everybody
wants to make is you know am I getting
this from plant or animal
and you know again I unfortunately this
has become sort of a contentious topic
and it's you know got its sort of
political religious overtones to it but
but if if you don't concern yourself
with any of those things and you just
think about biochemistry there's really
no ambiguity here protein derived from
animal sources are more bioavailable so
you can overcome some of that by cooking
the plant so once you start to cook the
plant and free it up from the fiber you
could you know liberate more of the
plant protein
but you're still always going to be
struggling with a bit of a
bioavailability problem that can be
anywhere from you know a 20 to 30
percent haircut you're taking just on
the net consumption of the amino acid
the second issue comes down to amino
acid quality
and if you're really concerning yourself
with hypertrophy
I think the three most important amino
acids
would be leucine lysine and methionine
and
these are amino acids that also you
don't tend to have as high a quantity in
plant protein now you can get them
and it gets especially hard if you can't
have like dairy or eggs so if someone
says look I'm a vegetarian I'm not going
to eat beef or chicken but I'm willing
to have eggs and dairy it gets a lot
easier you know eggs for example are
very high source of methionine
so what we typically will tell patients
is
rather than just fixating on the total
number of grams of protein you need to
eat which you may have a hard time
hitting if you focus on the number of
grams of leucine Lysine and methionine
you're getting in a given meal or a
given day that will almost assuredly get
your total protein quantity to the right
place so for me
that really meant I just wanted to make
sure I was getting
gosh probably six to eight grams of
leucine a day
comparable amount of Lysine at least two
grams of methionine a day and and you
know I use an app to track what I'm
eating just so that I can keep you know
see where my protein is coming from and
how much I'm getting and when and where
and that tended to work out pretty well
what is the name of the app if you're
willing to mention it yeah it's called
carbon I have no affiliation with it but
a friend of mine it's you know his app
and I like it
I guess my affiliation is that it's my
friends it's my friend's app
I'm glad you brought up the the Lucy and
lysine and methionine because I was
going to ask earlier if while you were
fasting but losing lean muscle mass over
time you were supplementing with say
branched chain amino acids in any
fashion
I was I used to always drink BCAAs
during workouts and for folks listening
there are three branched chain amino
acids
and you know leucine is hands down the
most relevant of them and and we know
from you know work that our mutual
friend David sabatini has done in his
lab
that you know leucine is a very very
potent mtor stimulator in fact it might
be the single most potent stimulator of
mtor mtor of course acutely you want
that thing stimulated it's promoting
growth you don't want it chronically
stimulated but you want it acutely
stimulated
the problem with branched chain amino
acids and I got to tell you Tim I think
it's largely fallen out of favor so I
don't even consume branched chain amino
acids anymore during a workout I'm
literally just consuming an electrolyte
drink that's it
the problem is one they don't stick
around long enough in their free form
and two you're just not getting enough
of them
the third thing is the temporal nature
of when you take them in being in the
workout or a couple hours after the
workout doesn't really seem to matter
our our window in which we can
synthesize new muscle is sufficiently
broad that even for an untrained
individual who has a narrower window
it's totally reasonable to say look just
make sure a couple hours after that
workout you get in your big protein meal
so instead today I just use high quality
whey protein post-workout and I don't
trouble myself with consuming any
protein in workout
so I just want to mention a few things
for folks so number one
there's a huge difference between no
animal products and lacto ovo vegetarian
and one example of that would be Bill
Pearl who became Mr Universe as a as a
lactoba vegetarian so it does make a
huge difference the second I'll just
mention we may come back to this and
discuss keto at some point we have
discussed it at length in previous
conversations but the
gluconeogenesis is one of well is I
suppose the the pathway by which you can
knock yourself out of keto if you
consume too much protein and not enough
fat
liver just loves to convert that into
glucose and then but a big bada boom
you're out of ketosis
or at least out of out of sort of the
range that one would be aiming for so
let's come to the book so you and I have
had many offline conversations about the
book we'll probably not repeat some of
them
why did it take so long
and I believe there were three
iterations over six years and the first
iteration had a zero translation into
the final version something along those
lines maybe you could correct me if I'm
getting that wrong but no that's correct
why have you taken so much time to work
on this book yeah it's a really good
question Tim I think there are probably
several factors some of which are
related some of which are not
I think on one level
my appetite for how good quote unquote I
needed this book to be was very high so
unlike you Peter yeah yeah look I think
there were some people out there who can
churn out a book a year and more power
to them
but you know the way I viewed this book
was that this is sort of the one and
only book I ever want to write
will I ever write another book it's it's
hard for me to ever imagine the answer
that question is yes but maybe maybe at
the end of my life I'll have something
else to say but as as I'm 50 years old
now and I'm at the midpoint of my life
or slightly past the midpoint of my life
I feel like everything I ever want to
say on this particular topic is in this
book and therefore
you know it was just a very long book
right I mean it took like the final
version is probably 140 000 words the
version I ultimately submitted was 200
000 words like this has been chopped way
down by 30 into what is still you know
obviously a a book that is is quite long
so that's part of it I also think part
of it is
and maybe you can relate to this Tim I
don't know we've never actually talked
about this but
I think there's just a vulnerability
that comes with writing in this manner
that is unlike all the writing I've done
in the past so I've been blogging
insanely for 12 years
that's different right you're not really
putting yourself out there when you
write a blog post
you don't have to read the comments that
people write you don't have to pay
attention to any of that stuff I think
when you write a book
you are really saying to people like
here I am tear me down you know
and I just think there's on some level
maybe it's embarrassing to say this
there's just been a little bit of a
reluctance to to kind of be that
but yeah again for lack of a better word
vulnerable just to sort of say okay you
know I'm willing to say everything I
have to say on a subject matter and now
let the arrows come flying and and
that's again I don't know that that
makes sense but I'm sure that anyone who
does something very public feels that
way
but it's different with podcasting which
I don't have a problem doing and it's
different with blogging and which I
don't know what I'm doing but this
strikes me as maybe what an actor feels
like when they make a big film or a
director or again like like an author
like you so I think there was a little
bit of subconscious dragging my feet and
hey maybe I can just keep working on
this book forever but it'll never
actually come out
so I do identify and I would say for me
at least part of that is when you put
out a book it might be one of the 20
books the publisher is working on that
season but especially if it's a book of
this depth and also I will second
vulnerability not just on the personal
side when discussing physical health but
also in the chapter
or a city section really on mental
health psycho-emotional health and so on
I mean you really show sides of yourself
that are
uncommonly shown I think in some of your
other formats and
unlike a blog post it's very hard to
just delete a book from the world once
it is published so I number one think it
was right to take it seriously and
however long it takes to do a book of
this quality is the time that it takes
and I think that's the way it should be
and I will say just as a side note I
mentioned this to you and you know this
that my dad who has struggled in various
ways with health for decades now
picked up your book which I had at home
when he was visiting me in Austin and
could not put it down and that is I have
to I won't get into all the details of
why this is the case but like if that
isn't a testimonial I cannot imagine
what is to the extent that I ended up
giving him my copy so he could take it
home so that should tell everybody
something I didn't know that Tim thank
you because when you guys came over he
mentioned how much he was liking it he
had just picked it up but I didn't
realize he'd finished it and he enjoyed
it so thank you that means a lot yeah
definitely and with that
let's talk about perhaps this is a good
place to start objective strategy
tactics
why are these three pillars important
and why all three
you know I learned about this stuff
about a decade ago when I was working on
a problem that you know is irrelevant
now but I think the the message was
important right which was I think I had
a vague sense of what the objective was
and my immediate tendency which I think
is normal and I think we all do because
I don't think anyone's hardwired to go
through the middle step was to go from
objective to tactics in fact I think
most people just kind of go to tactics
without even thinking about objective
and certainly not having that strategy
piece in the middle makes life really
complicated so the first thing I think
is to understand what's the difference
so
objective is pretty straightforward
it needs to be stated it should be very
clear though
so for example my objective might be to
live longer okay
if you said well what are the tactics
now what should I eat how should I
exercise you know do I need to take this
supplement or that supplement
the probability that you were going to
come up with the right set of
instructions is
vanishingly small right it's somewhere
between zero and Epsilon small even if
provided this list this Lottery list of
tactics well I guess the question is how
do you come up with the list right like
how are you filtering on that list right
so so there's no shortage of tactics
that one could think about because the
world is Rife with everybody offering
their tactics it's not like I'm not
suggesting tactics but what I really
want people to do is say look let's
anchor to a strategy so for example
if one of your objectives is okay I'm
gonna live longer it's like no no let's
deconstruct that what does living longer
mean
well to understand what it means to live
longer you have to understand what ends
life
well what ends life is a very clear and
easy to understand data set so let's
look at it and let's look at it in great
detail we call this the death bars
analysis so what are the death bars
well it turns out if you're over 40 you
don't smoke we can really clearly tell
you that there's an about an 80 chance
you're gonna die from
atherosclerotic cardiovascular disease
cancer neurodegenerative disease or
metabolic diseases you know such as type
2 diabetes and things like that
and probably I would include accidental
death in there so falling or Automotive
accidents
okay so that's that's an important
Insight because now you start to work
backwards from there so if you so wait a
minute you think if I want to live
longer I have to avoid those things ah
okay how do I avoid those things well
let's start with the chronic disease
bucket
there's two ways to think about that
right this is I love when things turn
into somewhat binary decisions is one
way to live longer to live longer with a
chronic disease
or live longer without a chronic disease
so it might not be entirely obvious
which of those is true but if we look at
the data it's pretty clear
the data unambiguously make it clear
that you will live longer if you can
extend a period of time that you live
without a chronic disease rather than
extend the period of time you have the
chronic disease
so in other words it's better to get
cancer later in life than to live longer
with cancer as one example it's better
to have your first heart attack very
late in life than have it early in life
and then be right on the verge of having
another one as time goes on
well just by going through those very
simple questions all of a sudden you
start to formulate a much clearer
strategy for living longer that points
you much more clearly towards this idea
that I talked about the book called
medicine 3.0 rather than medicine 2.0
and once you iron all that out then you
start to get into the tactics oh all
right okay so how does nutrition layer
on to this how does pharmacology layer
onto this how does exercise layer onto
this
Etc
so I want to just share an anecdote
which will not surprise you but when I
published the four-hour body and no
doubt you're going to get a lot of these
types of requests if you haven't already
I had a number of
not morbidly obese but out of shape CEO
friends say look I just want the index
card just give me the index card with
the seven things I should do and I'll do
those seven things can you guess what
the compliance rate was with that Peter
what's your what's your guess
very close to the success rate of
skipping the strategy step
zero percent not a single one of them
actually implemented any of it
and
just as a quick side note which you
might find entertaining I had an amazing
Mega successful investor named ed Thorpe
on the podcast who's if not if not over
90 90 right now he's in excellent shape
and he plans his travel around
minimizing time in automobiles
and he's sort of run through the numbers
just as a as an anecdote very
underappreciated cause of of morbidity
and mortality yeah
I think about it a lot
yeah we might come back to as I think
about it different seat belts that you
can use in life which initially I don't
want to turn this into a Tim Ferriss Ted
talk but initially thought about with
respect to covid early
which was like what minimally
inconvenient easy to do things can you
do to dramatically mitigate risk right
like so even though you've never had a
head-on collision the downside of having
a head-on collision is so high that most
of us will wear a seatbelt when driving
on the highway most of us will have a
fire extinguisher in the kitchen even
though there's never been a fire in your
kitchen Etc so where else can we take
very small steps that are easy low cost
that prevent
dramatic downside risk so we may come
back to that but I want to bring up a
graph that you have in your book page 28
for those who want to find it
where if you remove the top eight
contagious infectious diseases it
appears that we meaning we're
we're accounting for the Advent of
antibiotics at least as I understand it
we haven't really seen a material or at
least large change in mortality rates
since what 1900 if you sort of account
for some of these variables why do you
think that is
because certainly most people don't want
to die
yeah so so you're absolutely right so
life expectancy since 1900 to today has
increased by twofold it's remarkable
it's gone from about 40 to about 80
right plus or minus but that's
directionally the change we've seen in
call it 120 years
and I do think that understandably it's
tempting to tout that as
the marvels of modern medicine and
you're thinking well oh my God we went
from 40 to 80 in 120 years the next 40
just based on Moore's Law that's got to
get us to like 160 right okay maybe but
let's take a closer look at the data so
you do this very simple analysis which
is okay
let's go back to 1900 and March forward
but when we go through the mortality
tables just strip out the top eight
leading infectious disease causes of
death
and what you see is exactly what you
describe there is now no change in
mortality from then until now
effectively there's a little bit it's
been a little bit better
and I think what it speaks to is
two things one is the remarkable success
of medicine 2.0 in solving acute care
an infectious diseases
and the remarkable failure of medicine
2.0 in addressing the chronic diseases
that sat under
the surface of the water waiting for the
tide to go down
and those would be
presumably the four or five
likely causes that you mentioned earlier
perhaps this is a good place for you
just to
Define or describe briefly medicine 2.0
and Medicine 3.0 so it's probably
easiest to just for the complete to
start with medicine 1.0
medicine 1.0 was basically everything
that occurred
prior to the transition period of the
late 17th century into the late 19th
century so that 200 year period marks
the transition from when medicine had
absolutely no basis of science
whatsoever
so I mean we can mock it now but
truthfully they didn't have a scientific
method or a scientific tool so they all
they could do was sort of think about
the gods think about bad humors you know
come up with the best rationalization
they had for what was going on in fact
arguably the most insightful
thought that occurred in medicine 1.0
was thousands of years ago on the part
of Hippocrates who was the first to
believe that diseases Were Somehow
caused by nature and not the gods that
was truly a remarkable Insight now
beyond that he had no clue what was
going on but that was a remarkable
insight and that was probably the Apex
of medicine 1.0
with Francis Bacon in the 17th century
we had basically the first push towards
the scientific method
this this became really important and no
one has done a better job explaining
this than our mutual hero Richard
Feynman there's a great video which I'm
sure you guys can find for the show
notes where it's an old grainy black and
white where Feynman is talking about the
scientific method and he's saying look
you you make a guess
right you design an experiment it's the
guest is called a hypothesis by the way
it's just a fancy word for a guess you
design an experiment to test that
hypothesis you do the experiment you
compare the results of the experiment to
your guess
and then you decide to either discard or
update your hypothesis this was such a
profound concept that it basically
propelled us into medicine 2.0 and the
place where that Sean greatest was
unquestionably in the world of
microbacteria right of microscopic
organisms so viruses and bacteria
and so you know again that's a it's a
brutal bloody slog to go from you know
Semel Weiss to Coke to Lister but that
transition effectively brought us into
the modern era where hey all of a sudden
doctors were washing their hands and not
operating on people with dirty hands and
you know and of course eventually we had
antibiotics and eventually we had
vaccines
and you know taking smallpox and polio
off the table
and reducing the mortality of influenza
and having antibiotics all of that stuff
had such a profound impact on human
health that it cut mortality rate down
by a half and doubled our life
expectancy so now we're into the
maturation of medicine 2.0 we saw these
other amazing success stories I think
the two most notable by far would be
hepatitis C and HIV I mean to think that
we're at a point now where a virus that
is as tricky as HIV can basically be
rendered a chronic disease on the back
of Highly active antiretroviral therapy
is nothing short of amazing when I was
in medical school Tim we're not talking
like a long time ago this is 25 years
ago we were told hep C will never be
cured and it will break the back of the
U.S
and Global transplant infrastructure
meaning we're going to need so many
livers to put into all these people with
hep C that by 2030 the system will break
and lo and behold we have a drug that
within a manner of weeks will eradicate
this thing so again huge successes
Now counter that with what we've done
against cancer
when Richard Nixon declared the war on
cancer
before you and I were born it was more
than 50 years ago
the goal was to eradicate this disease
by the bicentennial in 1976.
well not only did that not happen but
here we are more than 50 years later and
survival for cancer is barely five
percent greater than it was
in 1970.
I could go on and on but let's just look
at neurodegenerative disease
so you were talking about six million
people with Alzheimer's disease in this
country if you add up those with Lewy
Body dementia and Parkinson's disease
we're talking about gosh another four
and a half million so we're looking at
more than 10 million people in this
country with very very significant
neurodegenerative diseases and that says
nothing about you know ALS and
huntingtons and things like that
we don't have a single thing like a
single thing that we can do to to cure
these people right we we have barely a
few things that can slow the progression
of their diseases
but we've made you know paltry steps
against chronic diseases
when you and I were born the prevalence
of type 2 diabetes was less than one
percent
today it's 10 effectively right so we've
seen a log fold increase in type 2
diabetes
a hundred to a hundred and twenty
million people in the United States
are metabolically sick meaning have
metabolic syndrome or pre-diabetes
for type 2 diabetes outright so
something's not working right and the
current system of medicine 2.0 doesn't
really seem equipped to address it it
intervenes late and by the time it's
intervening it's not really fixing
so this thing I'm proposing this idea
that of course I'm not the first person
to suggest maybe I'm the first person to
talk about it this way is we want to
kind of pivot to this newer way of
thinking about things which
deviates from medicine 2.0 and a couple
of really important areas
the first is in its timeline
so medicine 2.0 is largely focused on
treating disease
and
it's really interesting when I think
about it
because it's so obvious that I can't
believe I didn't notice it earlier but
when you're in medicine when you're in
medical school when you're in residency
when you're in practice you sort of need
a code for a disease you need a code for
a disease that you Bill for and you
treat
and prevention doesn't really fit into
that so you know when I went to medical
school I didn't learn a single thing
about nutrition or exercise or sleep or
stress management or emotional health I
learned a lot about pharmacology
and it's tempting at this point to say
well pharmacology is either good or bad
no it's it's both right like
pharmacology is good and it's really
valuable but over indexing it is bad and
ignoring all those other things is
problematic those other things turned
out to be far more efficient tools of
prevention
but if if no doctor learned about them
then why are we surprised that medicine
2.0 is unable to cope with that so so
one we have to understand prevention and
we have to understand the timeline for
prevention must start much sooner you
have to start doing these things long
before diseases are kind of ravaging the
system
the other big difference is that
you know as I talked about it the
scientific method was such an important
part of medicine 2.0 and with it came
something that I'm sure you've talked
about many times which is the randomized
controlled experiment this is the tool
that allowed us to do that thing that
Feynman described
the randomized control experiment is
really wonderful it is insufficient by
itself to solve the problem so medicine
3.0 needs to go from
what we call evidence-based medicine you
only do what the randomized control
trial says to evidence-informed Medicine
which is you take the insights from the
randomized control trials but you have
to then modify them and specify them to
a given patient
so those are really the huge leaps that
we have to kind of take to now make this
next transition
you say a bit more expand a bit or give
an example hypothetical or otherwise of
moving from the S I don't want to say
soul but
extremely strong focus on only making
decisions for patients based on RCT data
to what you're describing
exercise is a great example so you know
exercise would say okay the
you know the recommendations would be to
I'm going to give you two examples by
the way so this one's kind of a a
simpler one and then a more nuanced sort
of nerdier one but
the nameplate recommendation around
exercise is something to the effect of
like you know two and a half three hours
a week of moderately vigorous activity
but no one is like parsing these data
down and actually looking at what
metrics matter like how much strength do
you need to have the absolute lowest
risk in mortality how much
cardiorespiratory performance do you
need to absolutely lower your risk
literally four-fold relative to someone
in the bottom quartile
so do I have a randomized controlled
experiment that tells us that I don't
right no one's going to do that
experiment which is I'm going to take a
group of you know 10 000 people
randomize them to different levels of
training
increase each of their fitnesses to
relative levels and follow them
prospectively for the remainder of their
lives that experiment can't be done
never gonna happen right so instead we
have to be able to triangulate between
these other sources of data another
example maybe a bit more
glitchy might be
you know the way we might use different
forms of lipid lowering medication
so this is kind of a whole other tangent
we could potentially dive into which is
if you're really interested in
preventing heart disease which by the
way number one cause of death in men and
women in the United States and in the
world so it's sort of it's the four for
four champion of death
he's such the champion of death right
that for every woman who dies of breast
cancer there's like 8 to 12 women who
are dying of heart disease
so pink ribbons matter red ribbons
matter more
this disease would be largely
preventable if people didn't smoke
controlled their blood pressure and had
apob levels that were equivalent to the
levels they had as children
no one will do the clinical trial that
will get us there yet we have all the
mendelian randomization we have all the
mechanistic data and so
an evidence-based approach says look
we're going to Target LDL cholesterol to
100 milligrams per deciliter this
approach is going to say actually that's
probably insufficient for this
individual because their risks are
higher and by the way their appetite for
reducing the risk of this disease is
higher so we're going to take a more
aggressive posture even though the
recommendation in the literature is
going to be a far less aggressive
so
medicine 3.0 seems to comprise a number
of different
elements one of which is early
intervention or certainly much earlier
intervention hence early medical I can
only imagine and another
is medical literacy
and a more perhaps proactive approach to
education
and intervention on the part of the
patient right so it's not a passive
experience of being shepherded through a
system by a doctor or a team of doctors
who take a much more active role and I
wanted to chat about medical literacy
because what I've noticed just to give a
personal example
long ago wanted to potentially become a
doctor and certainly became fascinated
by competitive Sports and performance
enhancement that led to doing my best to
read studies and dig into the science
and understand as much as possible
I was I was unsure of the value of that
once I shifted courses and decided to do
other things but in the last I would say
decade as my parents have gotten older
as more and more of my friends have run
into issues it is astonishing how
valuable this minimum effective dose of
medical and scientific literacy has
become I mean it's it's astonishing how
much it helps you to navigate things and
make decisions and parse
signal from noise so I'd love for you to
speak to
medical literacy and how one can become
more medically scientifically literate
and certainly I would highly highly
recommend I'll just double down on this
if everybody read this book because I
think that your book does a good job of
this very very good job and I'll just
add a maybe a sidebar note
so I can hear myself talk a little more
which is that there's a I think a very
common Trend among people who are well
educated in some areas but not in
medicine or science to succumb to
scientism with a capital S where they'll
say well where's that they'll know the
term randomized controlled trial and
they will only they will insist that if
you say anything outside of the purview
of that that it is unsubstantiated
nonsense
and there are other examples of this
or they're all they're over they'll over
index on one thing as you mentioned
right so pharmacology it'll be either
good or bad but the fact is like
anything totally over indexed sort of
the paracelsus the dose makes the poison
type of problem
but could you speak to Medical literacy
somebody's listening they say you know
what I recognize that I don't know much
about this I would like to go about it
in a really effective way how do I do it
I think you and I have even talked about
this once before Tim and I and I don't
think I had a great answer for you then
and I don't know that I have a great
answer for you now it's really not
a simple thing to do
let's just start with the nomenclature
yeah my first day of medical school I
still remember one of the professors
saying
and I don't remember the numbers so the
story is not as cool because I don't
remember the actual numbers but I'm
making the numbers up but not the point
okay he said well all of you were smart
HotShots that just graduated the first
year class in college you have an
average vocabulary of X words
and X was like whatever number I
honestly don't remember it was called 20
000 words
he said in the next two years I.E just
in the first in the pre-clinical phase
of medical school we are going to add y
words to your vocabulary and Y was
bigger than x by like 20 percent
and those are mostly going to be Latin
Greek words by the way so
and he was right I mean it was sort it
was like learning a new language
so part of it is just the semantic
problem
now do you have to know all of that of
course not right but you know what's
proximal what's distal you know all of
these things kind of factor into this
stuff by far the biggest issue though
and this is the one that we try to
solve the most for on a weekly basis
right there's a reason like
you know that we go to Great Lakes to
write a newsletter every single Sunday
it's basically a class it's how do we
see something in the new a lot of times
it's like such and such a study is
published and the News picks it up and
writes a take on it that we think is
demonstrably wrong or a paper gets
published that gets a lot of attention
that says this and we think it's an
important paper and we want to highlight
it so we kind of try to use those things
as case studies and I honestly think
that's the most efficient way to go
about learning this now we did write a
series six years ago I think called
studying studies which is I think a five
part you know blog series that Bob
Kaplan and I wrote and I think it's
probably a great Foundation to just get
the basics
what is a case cohort study what is
observational epidemiology what types of
bias exist and how do you look for them
consider that sort of your basic
foundational knowledge set but
thereafter it becomes reps and the more
you can do this I think Lane Norton also
has a course that he just launched and I
think it's actually called reps but I
can't remember what reps stands for but
it's it's basically a scientific
literacy course in how to read studies
about nutrition in his case it's about
exercise and nutrition again we try to
cover everything in our newsletter we'll
talk about a drug study we'll talk about
a supplement study an exercise study all
those sorts of things so
those to me are the ways you go about
doing this you just have to
dive into it and kind of a little bit
overcome the fear of it I suspect it's
not unlike what you would say if I was
asking you
you know
like Tim I really want to learn Japanese
is there a particular app that I should
look at or this other thing I think in
the other day you'd say look man you got
to like learn it like you just you gotta
like here's the way to get the
foundational skills and then go and find
people to speak Japanese with
well let's actually use that example so
learning Japanese because I do think
they're parallels here
I think it it comes back to objective
strategy and tactics and I just want to
share a quote that's one of my favorite
quotes that also might help folks which
is from Ralph Waldo Emerson and the
quote is the man who grasps and says of
course people but the man who grasps
principles can successfully select his
own methods the man who tries methods
ignoring principles is sure to have
trouble this applies as much in medicine
developing scientific literacy or
learning Japanese right it applies in
all these places and so what I would say
and please feel free to pick this apart
is that
to learn Japanese is a very broad
objective so I would encourage someone
to refine that substantially and they
might refine it to I would like to be
conversationally fluent
which means I understand and can convey
maybe 80 percent of what I hear or want
to say in a conversation that does not
include specialist terminology that is
abstract like economics or
art fill in the blank right so you're
discussing what happened to whom when
I was born here I went to school there I
have two brothers whatever it might be
and with that goal then I would say for
the vast majority of people if and this
is a big if they were willing to make it
a part-time job let's just say with
three or four
hours per week
spread across
four consecutive days
that if they layered things properly
Within
three to six months if they then added
in a couple of kind of larger sessions
for bulk memorization and you can use
space repetition tools but the tools
don't matter as much as being really
clear on the objective
that you could become functionally
fluent conversationally fluent as I
described it which omits reading and
writing completely in Japanese scripts
probably within three to six months if
you took it super seriously and there
are some adjuncts I would add to that so
to give people maybe a glimmer of hope
on the medical literacy side I would say
if people started with
your AMA number 30. this is episode 188
how to read and understand scientific
studies if people
listen to that first and assume folks
before you listen to it that you're not
going to understand at least 30 let's
just make that an expectation so you
don't get frustrated and if they further
maybe read some of the case studies from
your newsletter made that sort of one of
the hours that they spend per week just
like the Japanese
if they maybe read
a book like bad science by Ben goldacre
who's an MD British so some of the
cultural contexts and examples may not
resonate for U.S readers but he runs
through some of the basics and they read
outlive
that making this literacy your part-time
job a very light part-time job for three
months is
one of the best investments you will
ever make in your life
I mean I just I really feel like the
payoff is so tremendous that
it's it seems almost crazy to not learn
and you don't have to learn a hundred
thousand words but you need to be
familiar with let's just call it a few
dozen Concepts
you'll be able to look at PubMed or
databases of studies or at least
abstracts not going into all the
supplemental stuff and makes some sense
of a b or c are there any suggestions
you would have for just becoming
familiar for with what the scientific
method actually entails right so I could
think read the Wikipedia entry as a
starting point but for instance where a
lot of smart people
or seemingly smart people screw up with
the scientific method is your guess
although it is a guess aka the
hypothesis needs to be falsifiable right
and a lot of people start with
completely impossible to falsify guesses
and you're painting yourself up shit's
creek without a paddle any suggestions
for how people could at least become
familiar with like the scientific method
and what that means as far as structured
thought and process
I don't off the top of my head have a
resource that I can point to I agree
with you that there's so much more
Nuance to it than just understanding
kind of the
caricatured version that I explained
earlier
for example have you designed an
experiment is essential so even if you
have a hypothesis that can be falsified
if you design the wrong experiment to
test it you can miss out
this becomes very important by the way
as you start to look at studies if a
study is quote unquote negative how do
you know if it's negative because it was
too small in size and what we would
describe as underpowered versus it was
adequately powered but there was no
effect
at the other end of that Spectrum
sometimes a study will find a
statistical significance but it was
overpowered and that difference while
statistically significant is clinically
irrelevant now that kind of stuff we do
cover in the studying studies stuff
but I think what you're describing are
these more important heuristics
that truthfully maybe there is a great
book out there and I'm just ignorant of
what that book is that that kind of goes
through this but that's the kind of
stuff that I think you learn with with
practice and unfortunately if you're not
doing experiments I mean again I think I
learned most of this stuff not in
medicine but in the two years that I
spent at the NIH where
you know as a fellow but doing research
so I was a you know like a research
fellow not a clinician that's probably
where
I learned more than anything about how
to do science and so I think anybody
who's been in a in a lab is just
learning that but it's very informal you
know it's not at least for me it wasn't
a structured thing
yeah in terms of priorities I would say
folks
man I've seen so many people lost in the
medical system especially when they
suddenly have a
serious diagnosis
with with some form of cancer or
otherwise and they are absolutely
helpless because they do not have a
handful of Concepts that they've become
comfortable with and just a basic set of
terminology so at the very least look up
Sir Francis Bacon I'm sure there's a
biography an excellent biography out
there somewhere and it will no doubt
track the development of the I guess
baconian approach you know one thing
I'll add to this Tim before we leave
this topic is also for folks to look up
Austin Bradford Hill
so Austin Bradford Hill a scientist of
the kind of middle part of the 20th
century
to him we owe the Bradford Hill criteria
so there are I believe nine Bradford
Hill criteria which are the criteria
that we use to scrutinize observational
data so when you have epidemiologic data
how can you scrutinize them to
understand
and change your confidence in the
likelihood that these data are causal I
mean causality is one of the most
important Concepts in science could you
also just Define observational study
versus randomized control trial so
people have that just as an anchor so an
observational study doesn't have an
intervention so you you can observe
things either looking backwards so
things that already happen you can go
back and look at what happened you can
even observe things prospectively but
without intervening so saying
hey we noticed that you know there are a
group of redheads over here and they're
a group of brunettes over here and we're
just going to follow them for the next
10 years and see if the color of their
hair predicts their life satisfaction
you know making this up of course and so
you might get an answer from that
and say oh my God like the people with
red hair were so much more likely to get
melanoma
I mean this is devastating and
it must be that something about red hair
is causing skin cancer
but it must be that brown hair must be
reflecting the Sun and those people
aren't getting skin cancer
so there's a correlation right
do we know if there's a cause there do
we know if the red hair is causing those
people to get more skin cancer than the
people with brown hair the answer is
probably not right the answer is
probably that red hair is associated
with fairer skin and that that's the
issue because if you really wanted to
know if red hair was causal you would
randomize people to different groups and
and you would actually dye the pair in
one group one color and dye the hair and
the other group another color and then
you would follow them you see so what
Bradford Hills criteria allow us to do
is look at nine factors such as the
strength of the observation so what's
the actual magnitude of the observation
what's the reproducibility of it what's
the biological plausibility of it is
there an analogy to it is there a dose
effect to it and as you go through these
nine criteria which actually I think
actually do this a couple of times in
the book because so much of the data we
look at around nutrition and exercise
are unfortunately epidemiological we
can't do the controlled experiments
but it's what allows us to say when I
read a study that says 12 hazelnuts will
reduce your risk of death you know 12
hazelnuts a day and consumption reduces
risk of death by 10 I can look at that
and say total nonsense like that's just
epidemiologic nonsense conversely when I
look at epidemiologic data that say
people who are really really strong live
longer than people who are really really
weak by going through those nine
criteria I can be much more confident
that that is actually causal
so I'll mention two things the first is
if you're gonna get because we're
mentioning a number of different books
and this is not just uh to Bliss smoke a
Peter's ass which by the way was a real
thing I found a menu from the wild west
and it was like all these various things
you could have done to you and blowing
smoke up your ass was like 50 was the
most expensive so that's the real thing
so it's not just that I'm doing that but
if you're gonna buy one book on this
stuff get outlived because it covers a
broad spectrum and I want to also
mention
because I think this is really critical
and we'll probably come back to this but
it isn't just about extending life span
but extending Health span and having
like full optionality physically or
trying to preserve that to the greatest
extent possible for the longest period
of time possible I will add though that
people will see for instance and a lot
of this Medicals or scientific
literacies so you don't get fooled by
misinterpretation or sensationalism in
media because you'll see a headline
that's something like
bananas increase your risk of colorectal
cancer by a hundred percent and what
that means though if you dig into the
data is like all right your risk goes
from one in five billion to two and five
billion so it's just from a behavioral
standpoint it just does not matter at
all there's a book called How to lie
with statistics by Daryl Huff which I
think is a very fast read and that will
also complement everything that we're
talking about so let's look a little
more closely at
some of the content and interventions
and tools in the book and I'm not sure
this is a great way to to kick it off
but there's a an expression I've heard
at least applied to Medicine quite a few
times which is 50 of what we know is
wrong we just don't know which 50 and so
I'm curious to know what you have seen
kind of peeking behind the veil
at what is not working and what you have
then designed to address that misfire
in your practice and by extension in the
book right you mentioned a few things
right like APO B levels you mentioned
being very specific with exercise
prescription being extremely specific
and the the possibility of lowering
certain types of risks four-fold so I'll
let you tackle that however you want we
can start wherever it makes sense
we could probably talk about different
things within different different
buckets so starting with sleep right I
think that
you know with sleep I kind of like to
simplify things a little bit sometimes
so one thing that I think is happening a
lot right now is people are getting
probably
at least some people overly anxious
about what their sleep trackers are
telling them and so you know we've got a
problem where the pendulum has sort of
swung a little too far to the other side
where you know maybe 10 years ago nobody
thought at all about sleep and now
you've got a class of people me among
them who maybe think too much about
sleep and all of a sudden it becomes a
little bit counterproductive and we see
this in a subset of our patients and
the first and most important
prescription for those people is stop
tracking take the tracker off
let's just focus on the fundamentals
what time are you getting into bed and
what time are you getting out of bed if
we can within 15 to 30 minutes on either
one of those completely fix that
and completely toggle on the basic
blocking and tackling aspects of sleep
hygiene which have to do with food
alcohol light temperature noise Etc
I mean you're gonna be okay and I don't
really need to know what your sleep
score is and how many minutes of this
you know sleep versus that sleep you had
so I personally go through this myself
I'll go through phases of time where I'm
not looking at any sleep tracking device
and if I know I'm going to be in an
environment where sleep is compromised
which is basically a lot of the time if
I'm traveling I don't even take a sleep
tracker with me because why do I need
something to remind me of what's
probably happening how about I just do
the best job I can and be a little less
data focused so that's an example of
where I feel like
a couple of years ago I would have just
set more data is always the answer and
now I think I'm a bit more measured and
I say look sometimes more data is not
always the answer no yeah the flip side
of that is there's nothing that will
demonstrate to a person how much late
night food and alcohol are ruining their
sleep than a sleep tracker so I do think
it's really valuable to see that
for many of my patients that has been
the most decisive thing that has reduced
their alcohol intake oh for sure and
despite what a lot of the epidemiology
will tell people alcohol is not good for
you in any dose doesn't mean we
shouldn't drink it at all but let's not
dilute ourselves into thinking it's
actually healthy at some low dose it's
not so understanding that it's a toxin
will help you have a more measured
response you know my response to alcohol
while we're on that topic is if I drink
something that doesn't taste incredible
I pour it out like I'm never going to
tolerate a bad glass of wine ever
it's just not worth it
so since we're on it I'm gonna I'm gonna
pull us back to this question of data
probably through the lens of continuous
glucose monitors
and the best uses and maybe the most
common misuses for people who do not
have you know type 2 diabetes or or type
1 diabetes but
let's just sit with the alcohol for a
second so what are your personal rules
for alcohol consumption outside of the
if it tastes mediocre or shitty it gets
poured out which is a great rule but
what are your favorite types of alcohol
how do you personally navigate that well
I'll start with like kind of quantity I
would personally just say
there's going to be an insane reason to
have more than two drinks in a day
so it's somewhere between zero and two
and it's got to be a really good reason
to drink on more than three days a week
so in the back of my mind I'm keeping a
tally which is I really shouldn't be
having more than about seven drinks in a
week
and again seven drinks in one day is
very different than one drink a day for
seven days so it's the frequency and
it's the dose and that defines the
poison
the second thing is I really have to
make sure that that drinking is a good
three hours away from sleep
again when I say these things people say
Peter you must be a robot no I'm just
saying these are general principles
there are going to be times when I
violate that I think I posted something
on Instagram a little while ago which
was like the most rancid night of sleep
when I sleep data were comically bad and
the reason was we had friends over it
was very late we drank we ate you know I
basically went to bed you know by the
time they left at like 10 30 I went to
bed and we had just finished eating sort
of thing and not surprisingly my sleep
sucked the point I made in the post was
I'd do it again it was a fantastic night
our friends and the four of us hadn't
had dinner together in a long time so
you just have to be very thoughtful and
deliberate about the choices and
trade-offs that you make
as far as the type of alcohol
you know I think people I think love to
this isn't again an example of something
I think we tend to over index to oh you
know I drink a lot but let me tell you
it's just vodka and tequila so but it's
got to be good for me right it's like no
alcohol's alcohol right so
I love tequila I love Mezcal I love
really good wine and I love really dark
Belgian beer I'm not deluded to think
that any of those are healthy and I know
that there are some people who have you
know a horrible reaction to certain
types of alcohol well I would put that
in the same categories people who have a
horrible reaction to certain types of
foods don't consume them
but I think mostly where I focused him
is on how much am I going to drink
how close is it going to be to bed and
What's the total tally per week and
never exceed a certain tally in a given
day
you know I was waiting for the right
time to bring this up Peter but you know
I know that people say cookies are bad
for you but I've only been eating Nutter
Butters and I feel like well I'm kidding
I feel like that's the equivalent
although it's less of a neurotoxin
I do love Nutter Butters by the way they
are good they're so good I don't know
the last time I had one but oh my God
now that you reminded me that that's
horrible of you to do that
so well that'll that'll combine nicely
with the cgms so all the GBS and the
cgms so because you inside joke could
you speak to continuous glucose monitors
because for a long time
for I mean the even still now these are
broadly thought of as something that one
might only use if they have some form of
diabetes however there are people who do
not fit in those categories who use them
and I would love for you to just perhaps
give us a bit of an overview on cgms and
and what you have seen as the best uses
and how you use them in your practice
so a continuous glucose monitor is a
device through a really two big ones on
the market right now one is made by a
company called Dexcom and one is made by
a company called Abbott and the latter
is called the freestyle Libre so I think
it's a company that haven't acquired
many years ago these are devices that
are worn usually on the tricep they can
also be on the abdomen and they have a
little tiny filament that is quickly
shot in with a needle into the
subcutaneous space so the filament
remains after the needle comes out and
the filament sits
in a part of the body where it can
sample something called interstitial
fluid this is basically the fluid
between cells
to be clear it's not sampling the blood
so it samples the interstitial fluid and
it measures glucose level there and it's
basically calibrated to know based on
what the reading is there what the
glucose level is in the blood so a
continuous glucose monitor as its name
suggests is a way to give you real-time
information about what your blood
glucose is
as you said
for people with type 1 diabetes which
was the first use case
this is a very important innovation
because people with type 1 diabetes are
by definition dependent on insulin
so they are using insulin exogenously to
do the job of their pancreas which is no
longer working
and the pancreas of course is Like This
brilliant organ where it's the one
that's Auto regulating glucose via
insulin and when that goes away they
have to be the one to do it so now they
have this device that is at least giving
them real-time glucose information and
they can adjust insulin injections as
needed
it obviously didn't take long for that
to expand into a much much larger market
I.E 10 times the size which is people
with type 2 diabetes some of whom do
require exogenous insulin some of whom
do not but all of whom by definition
have a carbohydrate
and glucose tolerance disorder right the
very definition of type 2 diabetes is
based around
unregulated peripheral glucose
and this tool is therefore helpful right
it's helpful in first and foremost I
think knowing what to eat
you know I think historically we have
given people with type 2 diabetes
objectively horrible news and insight
with regard to what to eat you know I
mean we've just haven't really helped
them think through this problem so
the CGM makes it pretty clear that not
all foods are created equal when it
comes to managing glucose homeostasis
so everything I've said so far is
relatively straightforward I think where
are we now this is a great example by
the way medicine 3.0 versus medicine 2.0
so everything I've said so far
more or less makes sense if you're in
medicine 2.0 in fact I think we're
finally at the point where even medicine
2.0 is starting to accept the fact that
carbohydrate restriction is a really
good idea for people with type 2
diabetes
it's not the only way by the way so
caloric restriction in general will work
to improve insulin sensitivity which
therefore improves glucose regulation
but it does seem that carbohydrate
restriction as a form or a gateway to
caloric restriction has greater efficacy
than other methods
once we now talk about people without
diabetes
medicine 2.0 would argue a CGM plays no
role
okay is there a randomized control trial
demonstrating the efficacy of CGM in
anything outside of patients with
diabetes there is not
but now we have to get into the leap of
faith that one takes when you start
triangulating between other pieces of
data so we want to start with one which
is
in a population of non-diabetics is
there any evidence that glucose levels
matter
so type 2 diabetes is defined as having
a hemoglobin A1c above 6.5 percent
hemoglobin A1c is just a way to measure
how much glucose is stuck to hemoglobin
and by knowing what that number is you
can impute what the average blood
glucose is in that individual over the
preceding three months
so 6.5 which is the cutoff
translates to an average blood glucose
of 140 milligrams per deciliter
so the question then would be
if you take two people who don't have
diabetes one of whom has a hemoglobin
A1c of 5.0
and one of whom has a hemoglobin A1c of
6.0 neither of them are diabetic is
there any difference in their outcomes
so to put that in perspective the guy at
5.0 has an average blood glucose of
about 100 milligrams per deciliter the
person at 6.0 has an average blood
glucose about 120 milligrams per
deciliter so they're both outside that
diabetes range well the answer here was
actually pretty clear it is that there
is a difference
in fact for a non-diabetic population
the lower the average blood glucose as
estimated by hemoglobin A1c the lower
the all-cause mortality
okay so what's the implication now well
if the implication is
if you take a group of people who don't
have diabetes but want to live longer
I.E they want to lower their risk of
cancer they want to lower their risk of
cardiovascular disease they want to
lower the risk of neurodegenerative
disease
I think we can make a pretty reasonable
leap of faith that having a lower
average blood glucose is better than
having a higher average blood glucose
even if that higher average does not put
you in the range of a diabetic
so now the question becomes are there
tools to help us manage that because the
one tool would just be the A1c
you could say well I'm just going to get
my hemoglobin A1c measured every six
months
the problem with that as we know is that
hemoglobin A1c is very easy to mislead
it's very dependent on red blood cell
turnover
so the more rapidly red blood cells turn
over the more artificially low the
hemoglobin A1c will be and conversely
the longer the red blood cell sticks
around
the higher artificially the hemoglobin
A1c will be
and it's for that reason that we like to
use CGM
to actually get true measurements of
average blood glucose
when a patient who doesn't have diabetes
puts on a CGM for the first time they're
invariably
surprised there's this real learning
phase that comes you've done this Tim
you were doing this probably 10 years
ago you were your first one everybody
goes through this I remember you know
for me it's been about eight years since
I started
at first you simply cannot believe the
things that drive your blood glucose up
could you give some examples yeah I mean
like I I remember the first time I had
razor Nets I was like it's not like I
didn't expect it to go up I didn't
expect it to go up like that right
exercise certain forms of exercise and
by the way I'm not saying this is
pathologic there's nothing wrong when
you're exercising for your glucose to
Skyrocket if you're doing tabatas or
you're doing hit workouts
again it's not pathological but it's
super interesting and other things that
I think are pathological is how much
your blood glucose goes up if you had a
poor night of sleep you know yeah if you
have a horrible night of sleep your
insulin sensitivity gets crushed the
next day and your glucose levels go up
well that's actually very interesting
and that you know again maybe you could
argue that adds too much stress to the
fire but it's it's an Insight
nevertheless that can help drive a
behavior change I think in the book I
cover kind of my 10 best insights from
years of CGM and myself and patience
it's about different foods and like
foods high in fiber are going to have
one effect lean sources of protein
versus fatty sources of protein
all those sorts of things
ultimately I think CGM becomes a really
helpful tool for compliance it becomes a
behavioral tool we tend to gamify it a
little bit I know that when I'm wearing
CGM which I just happen to be right now
by the way I'm going to think twice
before eating something stupid
and again it's purely just because my
personality likes to gamify things right
it's like
yeah I'm tempted to go and eat all the
leftover waffles on my kids plate but I
just know it's like ah it's gonna shoot
my blood glucose up and I like not doing
that
where I think people get into trouble
and where the counter argument is
which is a fair argument is look if you
only index on blood glucose you could
still end up doing a bunch of things
that aren't healthy you know if you ate
bacon for every meal every day your
blood glucose would not go that high
but it's probably not the healthiest
choice and I would agree with that
but by that logic we shouldn't look at
body weight either
because by smoking cigarettes your body
weight will go down
so does that mean body weight is a lousy
measurement no it just means that any
measurement in isolation can be
ridiculous and can be gained
so we shouldn't ignore blood glucose any
more than we should ignore body weight
or body fat or body composition
we just have to understand that it's one
of many tools that we can look at in the
CGM again do I think this is like
necessary to live a longer healthier
life of course not it's simply one tool
that we have to help us understand how
to regulate one of the you know four
macronutrients
so I'd like to just add two things to
that so the first is people listening
who have not experienced a cgma here
puncture filament and imagine something
out of you know hostile too or something
like that I will say that in 2008 I want
to say it was the first time I used a
Dexcom which was the size of
the cell phone use like golden Gekko and
Wall Street is huge and the experience
of putting what felt like to me
subjectively to kind of barbecue tongs
into my abdomen was very unpleasant at
the time
I have however tried the latest
generations and you basically feel
nothing I mean it's so easy in my
experience I mean I don't know how many
of your patients report a lot of pain
with that but I was shocked by how
completely innocuous the whole procedure
was I mean it's very very mild very
quick very easy so I just wanted to
mention that and then secondly this is
probably applies more to your patients
than to you but in the book you
mentioned
the Hawthorne effect which I think was
first coined in manufacturing and
looking at worker Effectiveness or
output but that is the phenomenon
whereby people modify their behavior
when they're being watched right so I
think that is another
selling point for some form of
accountability is there anything you'd
like to like to add to that there are
some patients of ours who actually want
to utilize the Hawthorne effect and if
we agree mutually to do so we can see
all their data so they can just say look
I want you to be looking at my CGM data
every day and that's going you're an
accountability partner for me so I'm
going to eat less junk food
so what are some of the other perhaps
under emphasized or underutilized
metrics that you think are important
this could be in the realm of
metrics are tools right so it could be
forms of screening it could be blood
markers of different types
there are a few that come to mind that I
imagine are on this list
could be physical performance
markers of some type what are some that
come to mind
if we're going to just talk in magnitude
VO2 max and muscular strength stand in A
League of Their Own
so there's really nothing that's within
the zip code of those two metrics so
having very very high VO2 max for your
age and sex and being very strong
I mean again they have more of a
positive impact than any single thing we
can think of has a negative impact and
that includes
having end-stage renal disease like
being on the wait list for a kidney
while you get dialysis being a smoker
having high blood pressure having type 2
diabetes being obese the downside of
those things is relatively small
compared to the upside of having a high
VO2 max and being very strong
so we almost shouldn't even talk about
things until people are willing to
accept that fact and take the steps
necessary to address them
now you might say well okay how many
people can become very very strong or
have a very high VO2 max and the answer
is I don't know like I don't know
especially on the VO2 max side you know
to get into that top 2.5 percent of the
population where you really start to see
an enormous gap between you and
everybody else in terms of lifespan
yeah maybe maybe only
a quarter of the population has the
potential to get there
but the point is everybody has the
potential to be more fit than they are
you know outside of people who are
already doing everything they can and so
just going from being in the bottom 25
of the population to the 25th to 50th
percentile of the population
Cuts your risk of all-cause mortality in
half at any point in time
there's nothing that compares to that
like there's no drug out there that's
going to do that so
again I think we could talk about drugs
all day long and how I think they're
really important and how we can think
about controlling APO B and you know
rapamycin and Metformin all those other
things
all that stuff is you know it's it's
pixie dust compared to what these things
are
on the strength side the same thing
anyone who's got older parents knows
this
if you really want to watch somebody
suffer when they're aging
you watch them losing their cognition
and you watch them losing their physical
body you watch them lose the ability to
move around with ease to to have balance
to be pain-free all of these things well
a big part of that is being strong
you know strength is
something we can actually hang on to as
we age you know we lose quickness long
before we lose strength
and
you know that's that's the good news the
bad news is it you have to be very
deliberate in how you train it right so
I'm sure on the podcast you've discussed
type 1 and type 2 muscle fibers so
people are probably familiar with that
why don't you reiterate that so we
basically have you know our muscles are
made up of these fibers they're very
unique properties so muscles are these
multicellular things where the the cells
are these long sort of fibers that
contract past each other and that's what
creates the contraction of a muscle
but if you dig a little bit deeper you
have different types of fibers so you
have type 1 fibers which are fueled
mostly if not entirely by an aerobic
process
so they can use fat they can use glucose
but they do so in the presence of oxygen
primarily they're very slow to fatigue
which is mostly where the name comes
from
but they don't generate that much force
so these are the muscle fibers that are
mostly on display when you're you know
walking or just carrying out activities
of daily living right commonly called
slow twitch as you alluded to slow
twitch so you can do things for a long
period of time and these things don't
fatigue
conversely another subset of these
fibers are type 2 fibers and they're
called fast twitch muscle fibers and
they're fast to fatigue now they're much
more powerful so when a type 2 fiber
contracts far more is happening it's
generating far more Force
but it's doing so with a different
metabolic strategy so it's glycolytic
it's just using glucose or you know
broken down glycogen
and it's going to fatigue quickly so
it's accumulating metabolic byproducts
that are leading to fatigue so there's a
reason why if I say Tim jump up and down
as high as you can as many times as you
can this is not going to be a long
exercise right we don't have to sit and
wait two hours for you to finish that
you're going to fatigue pretty quickly
if you're doing maximal jumps whereas if
I say jump rope you could do that for 30
minutes easily and if you're you know
relatively fit person
so you get the sense of the difference
now as we age we lose power and
explosiveness
more than anything else and we lose that
the soonest and that's due to the type 2
fiber the atrophy of the type 2 fiber
and this again this comes back down to
strategy so that's why
if you want to live a longer better life
you have to have a strategy in place for
maintaining type 2 fibers
and you're not going to get that without
resistance
you won't you know you can't say look I
I play tennis every day I walk every day
those things are great they're not doing
something for your type 2 fibers yes let
me hop in for a second because I want to
get
specific on that because I think some of
the
approaches or tools might be counter
intuitive for folks so first just some
random trivia for folks who might be
interested if you've ever carved a
chicken or a turkey neither of those
like to fly very much and the breast
meat tends to be white and then you have
the dark meat well there you have sort
of type 2 type 1 fibers respectively so
just for the next time you're cutting up
a bird yeah the reason the legs are dark
is they have much more mitochondria
those are their slow twitch muscles
there that are you know heavily
dependent on oxygen delivery and
oxidative phosphorylation whereas the
white meat the breast meat is very fast
twitch quick quick quick flapping
doesn't have the mitochondria so that's
you know has far less of it and
therefore that's kind of a less
oxygen-rich muscle
when you dissect us of course you don't
see that difference our type 1 and type
2 fibers are less clearly separated
so if someone wants to improve strength
correct me if I'm wrong but you have a
number of maybe they're not just
heuristics I mean they're direct
indicators but you have a number of
things that you focus on and I'm sure
there are many others but in the
strength category I would love to know
how you define very strong and perhaps
this would be a place to talk about or
at least include hand strength
Farmers carry
or or anything else that you'd like to
to add that might not immediately show
up on someone's kind of mental radar
when they're thinking of strength
yeah I mean there are a handful of
strength categories that we think really
matter and and just ideas that are
important when you think about strength
so
one of them is the importance of
understanding eccentric versus
concentric strength and how both are
very important I actually put something
up on Instagram the other day about this
where I
you know just explained that the
concentric phase is basically the go and
The Eccentric phase is the slow so you
accelerate through concentric Force
which is the force a muscle generates as
it is shortening that moves you forward
the eccentric phase which is equally
important but oft ignored is the
strength or the force that a muscle is
exhibiting as it is lengthening that's
what's decelerating that's what's
slowing you down
Andy Galpin I think recently talked
about
a great metric and I agree this is a
fantastic metric something you know I'll
check mine constantly is how far a broad
jump can you do
so
I want to make sure that I can do a
standing bra jump that's higher than my
height laying down
so you know if I'm five foot ten I want
to make sure I'm jumping at least six
feet on a broad jump and a broad Jump's
a really interesting test it's a
profoundly extreme example of concentric
and eccentric strength in the same
movement
if you're just standing there and you
want to jump six feet in front of you
that requires an enormous explosion
that's a very high concentric load but
guess what if you want to not break your
nose when you land and destroy your
knees you better be able to decelerate
yourself and slow yourself down that's
an unbelievable eccentric ask
so while that's a very extreme example
consider walking up and down stairs
walking up the stairs is very taxing
concentrically
but where do most people get hurt in
life it's actually walking downstairs
and if you watch
especially as people age the difficulty
they have in slowing themselves down
when they're coming downstairs or taking
a step off a curb this is where people
are falling and breaking their hips it's
far less that they're falling due to
concentric weakness and far more that
they're falling due to Eccentric
weakness
so therefore principle number one in our
strength training is always be doing
both not necessarily in the same
movement not necessarily focusing
equally on a given day but everything we
want to do we want to make sure that we
are hitting the concentric and The
Eccentric phase not just the more
obvious which is the concentric
now does that take the form of Simply
accentuating the lowering in the case of
say trap bar deadlift or something like
that where you have something like two
seconds up four seconds down or does it
take other specific forms there are very
specific exercise that you'll do so for
example like a you know a Nordic rollout
you know Nordic fall you know for a
hamstring exercise where you're you know
what I'm talking about when you're
kneeling on a mat and your feet you're
held in position and you sort of allow
yourself to slowly come down that's just
purely eccentric misery requires quite a
bit of starting strength to do well and
and truthfully we wouldn't have people
do that out of the gate you'll do that
with assistance to start because most
people simply don't have the hamstring
strength to do that yes it can be
accomplished greatly by using
slow what we call negatives so focusing
just as much on the negative as the
positive so for example one of my
favorite exercises to do are step UPS
because
one it's a single leg exercise it's a
beautiful hip hinge and we can talk
about it in some detail in a moment
because the hip hinging is another one
of the big principles and
it allows you to do a very nice
isolation of The Eccentric on the step
down
and you really have to be able to
control that if you can't control it
you're using too much resistance
obviously so hip hinging is another big
important principle and again hip
hinging when people think about that
they think that does that have to be a
squad or a deadlift no it doesn't have
to be it can be a hip Thruster it can be
a lunge it can be a step up I mean I
think the Step Up might be the single
most important one for people to do
because it doesn't have any axial
loading could you explain what you mean
by that when you're doing something like
a squat or a deadlift but you there's
there's weight that is basically pulling
your spine down to your hips in the
squat it's because the weight is
actually sitting there in the deadlift
it's because the weight is being the
force is being transferred through your
arms there but in either case you are
loading the axis of your spine
and that's fine if you know how to do it
safely but as you know you know having
done these things like that's not just
something you can walk in off the street
and do you really have to be coached how
to do that stuff safely and
you know stepping up onto a block is
something that's much safer to do
and it's also something that you can do
with a single leg at a time and
therefore you get to see what your
asymmetries are because we all have them
I mean I am so deep down the rabbit hole
of Step ups that I can't even like
explain the nuances in oblique
compression pelvic angles and the
difference between when my left and
right leg do it
but it you know tinkering with that
stuff allows me to work out so many
Kinks with with how my body works
you mentioned another one earlier which
is being able to carry heavy things
you know this is just such an essential
skill for our species it's something
that we do better than anything there is
no animal that can carry with their
hands what we can do
certainly a strong male but even a
strong female can carry their body
weight in their hands
you know half their body weight in each
hand is not it's not an insurmountable
ask for us would that be a hypothetical
Target for your patients
yeah we would like to see our patients
carry half their body weight in each
hand for a minute for a minute so walk
around with half your body weight any
chance for a minute yeah and having
strong hands is you know it's it's one
of the most correlated findings with
longevity so we talked earlier about
like what does it mean to be really
really strong well unfortunately the
data on this are based on what the
studies show and the studies are testing
you know interesting things but they're
not exhaustive right so they're usually
looking at grip strength
leg extension bench press are the most
commonly tested things
but grip strength comes up over and over
and over again in studies as such a
proxy for longevity
you know lower risk I think there's a
figure in in my book that talks about
The Unbelievable monotonic decline in
both the risk of onset of dementia and
death from dementia as grip strength
increases
again just kind of go back to the
Bradford Hill criteria and you look at
the strength of the associations you
look at the consistency of these
associations you look at the dose
effective these associations very hard
for me to believe that there isn't
causal relationships here and that being
stronger training to be stronger will
actually improve outcomes not just that
strength is a marker of Health which is
obviously correlated with living longer
if that makes sense yeah there's a
distinction there
so yeah we think that carrying things is
very important
but yeah I'll go through different
phases as you know I love rocking so
that's another thing that I think is
just a great all-round way to kind of
now combine two different types of
exercise something that's part of
strength and something that's part of
endurance is so just for people who
don't know rucking is just basically
carrying a really heavy weighted
backpack
probably one of the most important tools
used in the training of special forces
in the military I mean you know you we
have so many friends that have been
through that and and
it's I'm amazed at how much they rocked
like it's yeah sort of like eight hours
a day they're just walking around with
75 pounds on their back if not more what
is your protocol methodology look like
for Wrecking
so I use 55 to 60 pounds and I'll
typically do an hour Ruck and because of
where I live it's really hilly so I
really like that going up the hills I'm
going hard you know I'm really pushing
my cardio up the hills and I'm trying to
find the steepest Hills possible to come
down because that's working that huge
eccentric gear it's really forcing me to
be able to decelerate on the way down
those Hills with a lot of weight and
you're not getting the pounding I mean I
think that's the beauty of it right is
you're not pounding your knee with the
impact you would if you had to run to
produce that effect yeah that's probably
the most compelling reason that I
started rocking a few years ago and
especially in in preparation for for
certain Alpine hunts and so on I did a
ton of rocking and the collateral
benefits I mean they're not really
collateral I mean the direct benefits
where this sort of holy [__] effect that
sometimes I've seen with kettlebell
swings and other things where this
translation that you wouldn't expect
pops up in all sorts of ways and I used
to be a runner but I ended up
you probably didn't know this but I used
to be a cross-country Runner when I was
say up to about age 15 and then through
poor choices like doing lots of
wrestling and other Impact Sports
developed knee issues and so stopped
running but I always missed the
sensation of getting a good workout
while walking or or moving in some
Fashion on ground and rocking solve that
coming back to VO2 max so VO2 max I've
always wondered to what degree someone
can improve via to actually spoke to the
benefits even if you're moving from say
25th percentile the 50th percentile huge
benefit right I mean I think you said
halfing certain mortality risks what
have you found to be the best approaches
for improving VO2 max
well first off it can actually be
improved quite a bit I think the
research out there understates how much
it can be approved because the research
studies are relatively short so it's
true that in a 12-week study you might
see you know kind of an eight percent
Improvement or ten percent Improvement
I would say that's just the tip of the
iceberg right we're we're not talking
about 12 weeks of training here we're
talking about a lifetime of training and
we're talking about 25 50 Improvement in
VO2 max that anybody who's been involved
in serious training will see all day
long so the how is also very important
the analogy I like to use which I'm sort
of borrowing from one of my old cycling
coaches is that
think about building a pyramid the VO2
max is the height of the pyramid so if
you want to build a really high pyramid
it also has to have a really wide base
so the key for building a high VO2 max
is saying I'm going to spend about 80
percent of my aerobic training time in
zone two
and this is counterintuitive right A lot
of people think oh my God if I want to
build a high VO2 max it has to be all
intense training no you have to first
and foremost build that huge aerobic
base that is the pure Foundation that
allows you to make the peak higher so
once you have that aerobic base that
other 20 of the time is used well above
so basically most people are training
too hard to build the base but not hard
enough to build the peak so they're in
what I kind of think of is garbage
training Zone
yeah yeah but it's like you know that's
sort of the problem with doing a lot of
sort of fun classes and stuff like it's
absolutely better than sitting on the
couch for sure but it's not specific
enough to achieve this goal so you
really want to kind of separate that
zone too from that zone five and when it
comes to VO2 max you basically have to
be in the three to eight minute range
is the sweet spot so it's got to be
intervals that are about three to eight
minutes so three minutes at the low end
meaning you're doing something that is
so hard you can only do it for about
three minutes and at the high end eight
minutes if you can do it for more than
eight minutes it's not doing a lot for
your VO2 max if you can't do it for
three minutes it's also not doing the
maximum amount of your VO2 max and just
for clarity that's the zone five that
you're referring to building the peak
yep exactly and here you're typically
doing about a one-to-one work to rest
recovery that's how hard these intervals
are if you do three minutes at whatever
that output is you're going to need
about three minutes of recovery before
you can do it again so we typically say
look a good starting point is four by
four
on four off four times
that's just a great workout to start
just doing that workout once a week
so let's say three days a week you're
going to do your cardio and it's going
to be kind of the low end zone two
cardio one day a week you so you pick an
exertion level that you can barely get
through four minutes of it you can do it
but you know leave a little bit left in
the tank but not much and that you need
four minutes to recover and then you do
that four times
sandwich between a warm-up and a cool
down if I'm understanding correctly that
would be the building of the peak what
does the zone 2 training look like
for you or your clients long and slow I
guess what I'm wondering is aside from
subjective perceived exertion is there
a
heart rate
range or anything else that you can use
as sort of a proxy indicator so people
can have something to aim for yeah once
you get fit enough lactate becomes
really good so measuring lactate with a
point of care like a finger prick device
is what I do yeah and you're you're
looking for a lactate level of about 1.7
to 2 millimole for most people is the
zone
for people who aren't yet fit enough
their lactates are usually going to be
way higher than that while they're still
training that energy system or if people
just don't want to do that and for those
people rpe rate of perceived exertion is
really the best way to do it and it's
far more accurate than heart rate
so the rpe is you should be able to talk
but you don't want to so today I did a
zone two ride I spent the entire this is
very unusual but just because of the way
it was today I spent the entire zone two
on a phone call my entire workout was on
a phone call
there was absolutely no confusion on the
part of the guy on the other end of that
line that I was on my bike and that I
wanted him to talk more than me like I
was breathing like this it was like
okay so
yeah you know like I mean that's that's
kind of how I was going at it I can
nasally breathe when I'm doing zone two
but it's I'm right at the limits of what
I can do and it's very easy for me to
nasally breathe like I don't mouth
breathe at night or anything like that
so that kind of gives you a sense of it
if you can talk pretty easily while
you're doing it like if you're out on a
walk and you're talking to somebody
that's too easy if you can't talk at all
that's too hard
mm-hmm
and I think that is by far the best test
and just to to give people some more
specifics for the zone two how long
would a Target session be how many times
per week and then similarly for the 4x4
let's just say that you described for
the zone five building the peak how many
times per week would you do that I think
if we can do that once a week is great
that's zone five yep zone five and I
think for zone two we think minimum
effective dose so again it depends on
where you're starting if you're starting
with you've never exercised in your life
I mean boy we'd be happy to get you
doing two 30 minute a week zone two
sessions but you very quickly will start
to adapt to that and I and then I think
we start to get into three hours being
the med oh well okay and that might be
kind of three 60-minute sessions or four
45 minute sessions
have you ever tried Peter and I'm just
gonna bring this up because we've spent
a good amount of time together and this
has been a a bit of a revelation for me
have you ever tried skinning on skis
going uphill with skins on skis I have
not but Lance Armstrong's a good buddy
and you know he moved out of Austin to
Aspen a few years ago and I I keep
giving him crap for it and I'm like dude
why did you leave why did you leave and
he's like yeah it's tough I mean
especially in the winter because he's a
summer sport guy but this is his form of
winter exercise and having him describe
it to me I'm like yeah I can see that
that sounds pretty awesome actually
so you know this Peter but people
listening may not I historically
am about as far from an endurance
athlete as you could possibly be in the
sense that if you look at my sports
career such as it was it's all
optimizing for trying to win very
quickly within three to five minutes
generally and
anything close to Extended exercises
always been
rightly and probably wrongly punishment
in my view I just have really disliked
it which means I've gravitated towards
weight training things like that
skinning and rucking are the two things
that have changed that my body including
like my low back pain and so on
feels so much better
when I am doing skinning and rocking I
will say with the rucking and I don't
know what your setup looks like but I
really benefit from having a waist strap
there are rucking backpacks out there
that do not have a waist strap and I
find those can cause some back pain if
if I have either too much weight use
them for too long or or both can I make
a Shameless plug for my friend Jason
McCarthy's company goruck yeah please I
have no affiliation but I love Jason and
I love the company so yeah the go Ruck
is the way to go here
you just need a backpack with weight but
if you want to invest in it they make
amazing packs you can buy these bolt-on
waistbands that allow you to support
because I'm like you I like to have 80
percent of the weight on my hips and
virtually none of it on my shoulders I
don't even
link up the little strap across my chest
because I want to be able to breathe
fully so I'm very light on the shoulders
incredibly heavy on the hips and you
know their packs and the weights that
come with them just make this a very
elegant solution so yeah totally agree I
also use gorex I'll give them a plug I
don't know the founders but ended up
honing in on on gorec and I will say
also the breathing component aside from
the loading distribution that you just
mentioned one of the benefits that I
find of rocking versus say a weighted
vest which are quite popular in the
CrossFit Community
is the the where you are bearing the
weight and also the ability to breathe
so those would be two advantages and I'm
sure there's a lot to be said for the
the weighted vests as well although
funny I'll tell you Peter I don't know
if I ever told you this this was
probably 2009 2010 I decided I was going
to try weighted vests and I was like
this is going to be fantastic I can't
wait and so I bought this monster which
was loaded up it looked like a suicide
bomber investor just had like all these
they look like canisters full of weight
how much did I weigh well okay I'll get
there so I thought to myself it's just
walking
at that point I was very seriously and I
know this is not winning any records but
for me it was a lot I mean I was
probably 180 and I was dead lifting 475
for reps which is as high as I got
and I thought to myself I walk all the
time let me get I think it was a hundred
pound vest so I get this 100 pound vest
and I put it on and I decided to go for
a leisurely you know two or three mile
walk and I get a mile out and I'm like I
can't carry this thing I've got five I'm
just gonna collapse into a puddle on the
sidewalk so I had to leave the vest on
the sidewalk this isn't like the mission
in San Francisco and go back to my house
to get a car to come get it and I
thought to myself if anybody steals this
thing they deserve to have it and not
surprisingly the weight vest did not
move it stayed exactly where it was so
yeah rocking I suggest rucking and start
lighter than you think yeah I recommend
people start with a sixth to a quarter
of their body weight yeah or to get you
as you'll end up dropping it somewhere
yeah and truthfully I think you know
Michael Easter who's written about this
extensively in in his book The Comfort
crisis which if your listeners haven't
read that not that we're trying to give
them more books to read but the Comfort
crisis I can't recommend highly enough
you know I think he said that even in
the military right now thinks that you
don't really need to go above a third of
your body weight so let gravity help you
more than that but you know sort of
anywhere from a six to a third your body
weight is probably the Sweet Spot yeah
where I've ended up this will make me
sound weak maybe but is right around 45
in some cases I've added a bit more
weight but I probably weigh 175 right
now 45 and then focusing on inclines
basically just going for the sort of
geographical altitude or not even
necessarily altitude but the incline
challenge rather than slapping on a ton
of weight and walking on flatter ground
the grape we've spoken about strength
we've spoken about VO2 max
just so I can
maybe explicitly explain why I've spent
and we have spent some time on this it's
because these are not purely the
implications are not purely muscular and
maybe this is a place to talk about what
you have learned about
a neurodegenerative disease and
specifically perhaps Alzheimer's because
I think this will all tie in and show
people that these sort of Cartesian
duality of body and mind is really
illusory
could you speak to that
probably the first time I took a hard
look at this would have been 2014 maybe
and at the time I I had one analyst his
name was Dan palichar
look at this in detail
and and God it was a
it was probably a six to nine month
project I mean it was a really really
exhaustive look at the literature
and
you know the deepest dive we could do at
the time of what do we know about the
prevention of Alzheimer's disease so
again we started with a very bold
hypothesis which we were not alone in
but most people thought was crazy which
was that these diseases have some degree
of prevention there is a way to prevent
these to some extent maybe not
completely but luck is not the only
thing or bad luck is not the only thing
that is driving these diseases we have
some control
and so to make a very long story short
after Dan kind of went through all of
this analysis and after analysis after
analysis
the thing that stood out above
everything else was the benefit of
exercise
and I just sort of told Dan to go back
to the drawing board I was kind of like
Dan I think he screwed this analysis up
buddy like there's zero chance that
exercise is actually the best thing here
like are you gonna now tell me that
chicken soup is the best thing for colds
like I wanted some insight here I didn't
want some stupid platitude right but it
turned out Dan was right and I was wrong
so I think I think the data are pretty
unambiguous you know in fact I'm doing a
podcast on this
I don't know by the time this one's out
it might be out I don't I don't know I
don't know but but I've got a podcast
coming out on sort of you know brain
health and here we are back again now
with you know many more analysts and
much more tools at our disposal to kind
of understand the literature and still
exercise remains the most important
modifiable Behavior we have to reduce
the risk of Alzheimer's disease and
probably Parkinson's and Lewy Body
Dementia by the way so I can't say that
for every single neurodegenerative
disease right I can't I don't have any
real insight into how you prevent Lou
Gehrig's Disease which is an absolutely
horrific disease that is fortunately
much more rare but when it comes to the
big three Alzheimer's Parkinson's and
Lewy Body dementia
exercise exercise and exercise matter
and part of that has to do with movement
Reserve so you know when you think about
Lewy Body and Parkinson's these are
primarily movement disorders right so
they're kind of on a spectrum right so
you've got Parkinson's at one end pure
movement disorder a little bit of
cognitive Lewy Body kind of bit of both
and then Alzheimer's much more cognitive
having a higher movement reserve and
having a higher cognitive Reserve are
protective
what do you mean by movement Reserve
just greater range of motion ability so
spectrum of movement patterns that they
can sustain greater physical capacity
right so you know people who are really
good dancers who are really good at
doing complicated coordinated
problem-solving things with their body
who have kinesthetic awareness
they're going to have a much slower
decline even when diagnosed with
Parkinson's disease for example
so we want our cognitive Reserve High we
want our movement Reserve High and then
on the other side of that you get the
sort of
kind of hormonal vascular metabolic
benefits that come from the actual
exercise so one is the benefits you get
from being in the state one is the
benefits you get accruing the state
could you expand a bit on the hormonal
effects and otherwise I mean I think
this is probably just because it has
words in the acronym that I like but
brain derived neurotrophic Factor Etc I
mean to what extent can you weight some
of these factors yeah I don't know that
I could tell you a relative weighting
but certainly bdnf is a very important
one so it's a very important you know
growth factor for neurons
but also of course when you think about
the metabolic effects and the hormonal
effects that come from what is exercise
doing to cortisol levels what is
exercise doing with glucose and insulin
levels I mean we we see an unbelievably
strong association between Type 2
diabetes and Alzheimer's disease
well again here's an example of where
medicine 3.0 I think gives you a little
bit more confidence to make the
extension which is look if type 2
diabetes is bad
having insulin resistance without type 2
diabetes is also probably bad
and therefore we want to take all steps
possible to maximize insulin sensitivity
glucose disposal all of these things
that fit under the bucket of metabolic
health
and again exercise is not unique in its
ability to act on those things nutrition
absolutely does as well
but boy does exercise have a profound
effect on those things
yeah
let's talk about training the trainer
Maybe by that I mean
the vast majority of people listening to
this will not be able to work with you
or practice like yours
what types of requests can they make of
their Physicians what types of tests
might they ask for
and this baby
a clumsily worded question but how can
they make their doctor and their
Health Plan per se better are there
any recommendations you have
yeah look I think that kind of comes
back a little bit to your medical
literacy question at the outset right
which is I think part of it is also just
being a bit more clear about what your
objectives are when you're finding a
doctor and understanding a little bit
about what their style is I mean
asking them what's what is their
philosophy on something how much time do
you spend learning about things that you
did not learn in medical school I go
back to something I said earlier which
was
there's
almost nothing I do today Tim that I
learned in medical school
I can't think of one thing and it's not
because what I learned in medical school
wasn't valuable it's just that and maybe
that's the wrong example by the way
let's be a little more let's be a little
less glib
if I look at the physicians in my
practice who trained in Internal
Medicine and ask the question what did
you learn in residency that you're using
today the answer is probably like 10 to
15 to maybe 20 Max
so where did that other 80 percent come
from
and I'm arguing that if you want to
participate in medicine 3.0 you have to
be able to learn outside of your
training
and I think that's that's a discussion
that should be had very deliberately and
not obliquely
so I think understanding where they sit
on prevention understand how they're
educating themselves what are they
reading what are they learning
and if the answer is hey it's not a good
fit great better to find that out before
you jump in
yeah and as we're talking about this two
things came to mind and please feel free
to dismantle this but the first is
to be able to assess medical literacy
you have to have a certain base level of
medical literacy yourself so I would say
kind of Step number one is developing a
working vocabulary and also Frameworks
many of which you you provide and
outlive such that you can actually
assess other people to some extent right
that's kind of step one the second is
that
if we think about many Western trained
or I shouldn't say Western Trend
Physicians who are
sort of schooled in a in a western
Paradigm as those focused on the sort of
addressing of disease rather than
prevention of disease broadly speaking
and it may be maybe unfair to paint so
broadly but let's stick with that for a
minute that as you think of your health
care it goes beyond just your primary
care physician and could very well and
probably should include people like
exercise physiologists are people who
are trainers
given given how much
overlap and integration we've discussed
in the course of our conversation and it
just occurred to me that and this I
think is is quite true that it's a lot
easier
not that you shouldn't look for
concierge doctors if you have the means
and that's a possibility by all means do
that but you can find excellent
excellent strength coaches
I would say much more easily than you
may be able to get yourself into a
economic position where you can
afford concierge medicine and the
payoffs
I'm not saying they're comparable but
the payoffs of having a good strength
coach or an endurance coach go a long
way so
those came to mind also
so let's just say they're asking these
questions of their doctors they find a
doctor
are there any particular
recommendations you would have a couple
of things come to mind that I have in my
notes Here related to tests to
request for instance I don't know where
you stand now on
Grail which I guess would be considered
sort of a liquid biopsy right
scans like pre-nuvo for instance and
perhaps more intelligent approach to
family history is something that I know
you cover in the book we do like to
speak to anything that might fall in
that category of things to consider
requesting
yeah we think it's really important to
be testing you know as I said apoe is
one thing for sure we really do want to
know that genotype and again
if you believe that Alzheimer's disease
has some element of prevention baked
into it than knowing that you're high
risk should be a valuable thing to
understand
when it comes to understanding
cardiovascular disease you know we care
deeply about apob
again being a more important metric than
LDL cholesterol or non-hdl cholesterol
or HDL cholesterol this apob is the
concentration of all atherogenic
particles so includes all the hdls vldls
ETC also knowing LP little a which is a
genetically determined very high risk
article that while it can't be modified
will allow you to understand how much
more you need to optimize for example
APO B so knowing LP little a knowing APO
B knowing APO e
there are other biomarkers obviously
that we care deeply about you know uric
acid homocysteine insulin
liver function tests cystatin C is one
that I think is largely underappreciated
so it's most doctors are using
creatinine as the measure of kidney
function creatinine is a joke actually
at some point I wish I had the time and
maybe I'll make the time to do a deep
dive into how it became the de facto
gold standard for measuring and
estimating glomerular filtration rate
it's an absolute atrocity so for a
person who's very low in muscle mass it
really overestimates kidney function for
a person with high muscle mass or who's
just exercised it really underestimates
kidney function but it virtually never
correctly estimates kidney function
whereas in systatency which is another
blood test probably costs a few more
dollars but certainly not much you know
it might be the difference of one dollar
versus seven dollars or something
completely more accurate and unlinked to
these issues of muscle mass and exercise
how do you spell sustatancy
c-y-s-t-a-systat like it's it says it
sounds phonetically I never I couldn't
do the spelling bee okay see why people
will find it on Google yeah exactly
don't don't ask me to spell anything
longer than uh all right how about on
the early cancer screening side
well again I think that cancer chapter
is probably a very long chapter for a
reason but I think one of the big
takeaways on that chapter is
the overwhelming evidence that treating
cancers when they are detected early has
significantly better outcomes than
treating the exact same cancer later on
down the line even using the same
cocktail of drugs I think the two
examples in the book I use are that of
colon cancer and breast cancer and
looking at
you know for example using the full Fox
regimen of chemotherapy to treat a
patient with adjuvant treatment meaning
so a person that had a stage two or
stage 3 colon cancer that is resected
and at least surgically you don't see
any gross disease they just have
microscopic disease you treat those
people with the full Fox chemo regimen
which is a multi-drug regimen and you
compare that to people who have
metastatic disease
the outcomes are vastly different right
in the latter group nobody's going to
survive for 10 years and very few of
them will make it five years in the
former group you know 80 plus percent
are going to survive 10 years
go through the similar example of breast
cancer the point here is
the fewer tumor cells you have
the smaller the burden of cancer the
fewer the mutations the fewer the Escape
mechanisms that are in place to evade
the immune system the more likely you
are to survive treatment and therefore
until we figure out ways to completely
eliminate cancer which I don't think are
going to happen anytime soon
we have to take a much more aggressive
posture towards screening
and acknowledge by the way the downside
of that so there's a significant
downside to more aggressive screening
but if you can if you can come to grips
with that you have a better chance of
beating cancer by far and to your
question now
Grail becomes one of the tools we would
think about doing that so Grail is a
company I guess it's currently are now
probably owned by Illumina
and it's it uses something called cell
free DNA so it
takes up blood a couple tubes of blood
and looks in there for tiny tiny tiny
amounts of DNA that are out of the cell
so most of the DNA if you know Tim if
you went at a DNA test and they took
blood they would take the DNA out of
cells in your blood they break down red
blood cells and white blood cells and
take the DNA but this technique looks at
all the DNA which is not in cells which
is you know a fraction of a fraction of
a fraction of a percent
they look at that DNA and by looking at
the methylation pattern of it so these
little methyl groups that are stuck to
it they impute two things one is cancer
likely to be present yes or no
and if yes can we figure out what organ
it is
you know where did it come from
these tests have a relatively low
sensitivity
meaning if a cancer is present their
their ability to detect it is not that
high
they have a very high specificity
which means
if no cancer is present they're very
likely to tell you that every screening
test has to be tuned towards sensitivity
versus specificity and this test is
tuned to very high specificity very low
sensitivity knowing the sensitivity and
specificity of a diagnostic test is only
slightly useful if you don't know the
prevalence of the condition you're
testing for
which is called the pre-test probability
you can't actually impute what's called
positive and negative predictive value
in other words what you really want to
know when you look at a diagnostic test
before you take it is if it's positive
How likely is it that I have the
condition if it's negative How likely is
it that I don't have the condition
that's positive and negative predictive
value respectively and you can only
answer that question when you know not
only the sensitivity and specificity but
what your pre-test probability is and if
you don't know that you would just say
what's the prevalence of the condition
and where I'm looking
so when you take
cancer screening in a general population
the prevalence is very low right I'd be
one percent two percent you know 100
people that walk into for a random
cancer screening you wouldn't expect
more than one or two of them have cancer
so with a low sensitivity and a high
specificity test you have if you do the
math you'll see very low positive
predictive value and very high negative
predictive value
and for that reason I I think initially
was
not Blown Away by the test because of
how low the sensitivity was
for low stage cancers like stage one and
stage two the sensitivity was like 20
percent
and that's that's the metric that I
cared most about I don't really care
about your sensitivity at detecting
stage four cancer we've blown it if
we're waiting until that point
what is very interesting to me though is
when you start to look at this by
histology
and this to me is interesting if you
look at all breast cancer
the stage one stage 2 sensitivity for
detection is
20-ish percent
but if you look at hormone negative
breast cancer it's 75 percent
if you look at hormone positive cancer
it's you know 20 basically what do you
mean by hormone negative and positive so
one of the most important ways that we
identify breast cancer is by its hormone
profile so is it estrogen progesterone
and or her2 new positive so triple
negative breast cancer has the worst
prognosis so a breast cancer that has
does not express the progesterone
estrogen or her2 new receptors has the
worst outcome it's the most aggressive
breast cancer
and those cancers even at the same stage
are far more detectable they have a 75
percent sensitivity in low stage cancer
this tells us that we need to think of
liquid biopsies in a very different way
from how we think about quote unquote
anatomic screening
so a mammogram or an MRI or an
ultrasound are agnostic to the
properties of the cancer they are simply
looking at its presence in size
what this liquid biopsy might be giving
us a window into is the behavior of a
cancer why is it that a triple negative
I'm using the terminology looser but
let's just say I got a 75 chance of
catching it in the bloodstream even at
an early stage whereas if it's triple
positive which has a much better outcome
I'm not going to catch it very likely at
that stage might it be that because the
latter is not that lethal
and therefore it's not shedding and the
former is much more lethal and that's
why the cancer is spreading so
I think it's super early days on this
and I think these you know cancer
screening is definitely one of the most
contentious things that you know I
probably talk about in the book because
I do take I think a very different view
from the mainstream
which is that you know we have to do
this aggressively we have to do this
early I mean I'm I'm just 50 years old
I've already had you know I'm three
colonoscopies in at 50 right so you know
I just to me it's just as it's
unacceptable I think to die of
cardiovascular disease in the year 2023
I think it's unacceptable to die of
colon cancer and yet colon cancer is the
third leading cause of cancer death
foreign
I'm not going to name names but a friend
of mine put off colonoscopy for a few
years older guy and yeah I know who
you're talking about yeah stage four so
early counts early counts a lot and I'm
just going to leave a couple of
gingerbread Trails for folks because I
do want them to pick up the book I mean
there's so much we couldn't even scratch
the surface in our conversation but the
contrast between say CT angiogram over
calcium score or calcium scan I mean
there's so much we could dig into
immunotherapy and and many other things
but what I'd like to do you'll probably
get a kick out of this number one I
think you have some of the best chapter
names I've seen in a long time so I want
to give you credit where credit is due
and then where I think I'd like to go
is to ask you about by the way some of
those Bill Gifford might deserve some of
the credit my co-author I was really
struggling for some chapters with quotes
you know as you probably noticed each
chapter has a quote and I think Bill
probably came up with three quarters of
them oh nice I was really struggling
with the quotes because I I had some
that were okay but he would always come
through in the end with a better one so
well credit to Bill but what I'd like to
do just to give people a lay of the land
is actually this is going to sound
ridiculous but just read through these
briefly and then what I'd like to talk
about is
how and why you decided to include
the chapter the high price of ignoring
emotional health
so if you bear with me here I'll just do
a little uh recital
so so chapter one long game from Fast
death to slow death and I'm not going to
give the chapter numbers I'm just going
to go through these medicine 3.0
rethinking medicine for the age of
chronic disease we touched on this
briefly objective strategy tactics a
roadmap for reading this book
centenarians is coming into part two the
older you get the healthier you've been
eat less live longer question mark the
science of hunger and health one disease
to rule them all the crisis of abundance
the ticker confronting and preventing
heart disease the deadliest killer on
the planet that's my chapter as you know
if anything's going to kill me that
isn't an accident it is probably heart
disease The Runaway cell new ways to
address the killer that is cancer
chasing memory understanding Alzheimer's
disease also something in my family and
other neurodegenerative diseases
part three we're rounding the bend here
coming into home
thinking tactically building a framework
of principles that work for you exercise
Nature's longevity drug Training 101
training for the centenarian decathlon
which for those long-term long-term
podcast listeners that may sound
familiar and it's certainly been refined
and developed in the form that you find
in this book The Gospel of stability
relearning how to move to prevent injury
nutrition 3.0 you say potato I say
nutritional biochemistry that's the most
Peter thing I've ever read putting
nutritional biochemistry into practice
new rules for changing the way you eat
the Awakening tap into the power sleep
and then last but not least work in
progress the high price of ignoring
emotional health
why the last chapter well I'll tell you
something funny
when I had an early draft of the book I
shared it with a mutual friend of ours A
Hugh Jackman and Hugh
read it and his only feedback was that
should be the first chapter
you had a really solid argument for why
that was the case the publisher
absolutely said no chance in hell
and so it was either nowhere or at the
very end of the book
foreign
this was the hardest chapter to write
unquestionably it's the 17th chapter
that has very little to do with the
other 16. for reasons I won't
necessarily explain here but it's it's a
very different format it's a very
different structure
and it tells a very different story but
look I think for some people it might be
the most important chapter in the book
and I think for others it might be
totally irrelevant but that was a risk I
think that was worth taking
and I'll just say this I think you
alluded to this earlier on several
occasions
longevity without Health span is the
greatest curse in the world
right like to live a long life and to
suffer is not to live
and that suffering that loss of Health
span can be cognitive it can be physical
and it can be emotional
and that last one is so squishy that
it's hard to talk about in a medical
book
but that chapter is basically my way of
trying to do that
hmm
so I just want to give some
if you don't mind I'll give it a teaser
now there's there's a lot to this
chapter we're not going to dig into all
of it but
maybe we could start with and we won't
spend too too much time
as I'm watching the lighting and the sun
and the moon and the stars changing your
video because I know we've been going
for a while but are you open to
discussing the 47 affirmations that you
had to write in the context a little bit
of the context around that because I
think a lot of people listening to this
will identify
with certainly that particular instance
of your experience
yeah boy it's hard to explain that
without explaining where I was when I
was being asked to do that but sure you
can say whatever you'd like to so let's
just say I was in a rehabilitation
center where one of my homework
assignments on the first day was to
write an affirmation for each year I'd
been alive at the time I was 47 this was
three years ago so it was you got to
come up with 47 things to say about
yourself that are positive
and I couldn't come up with more than a
few I was sort of stuck at
four or five
until the 19th day
and then I really kind of had an
enormous breakthrough that
honestly in the book is
I I don't devote a lot of real estate to
it as profound as it is but but I think
a person reading this who's been where
I'm taking you will understand it
but I think once I reached that point
once I had that breakthrough
as I described in the book I was able to
write the remaining 43 of them
in
20 minutes
those 47 affirmations then became a very
big part of my kind of recovery contract
and for a period of about six months
I would read those twice a day every day
standing in front of a mirror which
sounds very sort of Stuart Smalley or
whatever that character's name was what
was his name smiley yeah something like
that okay right I'm good enough people
like me yeah that's right that's right
but I think for
for my problems this was a
such an important step this
fake it until you make it I was able to
basically use that in my you know that's
the term fake it until you make it has
such a negative connotation from Silicon
Valley and companies like theranos but
but in Psychology it can actually be
pretty valuable right if you start to
say something enough you will believe it
we think about that a lot in the
negative but it works also in the
positive
and
I think that in some ways that one
exercise became a very important Brick
in the Wall of
fundamentally altering my view of myself
and fundamentally
altering the stories I told myself
and I must say as someone who was there
in your life for that period and also
watching the steps that you took
including what you just described
I am so glad that you
included the chapter in this book
because I think a lot of people who
would like to optimize lifespan and
health span nonetheless find it easier
to think about the maybe hard measurable
edges of something that is physical
versus that which is currently
giving them the most suffering which is
some lack of equilibrium or
set of proper I shouldn't say proper
constructive lenses through which to
view life and themselves so I think it's
it's a real gift
and not one without I'm sure some
trepidation on your part to include this
in the book so I just wanted to
commend and thank you for including that
because I think it will help a lot of
people
thanks so much yeah I hope you feel good
about it Peter
Peter we talked about a lot
the sun has come the sun is gone is
there anything else that you would like
to mention before we
close any requests to people the book is
outlived the science and art of
longevity I'd never say this long-term
listeners will know this go get the book
this is a very very solid book that many
years have gone into not just in the
writing but in the living and
experimenting and refining
and changing of mind that is reflected
in the sort of adaptability and
principles in the book so
I do recommend everybody check out the
book of course earlymedical.com Peter
tmd.com there are many other places on
Instagram at Peter attia MD is there
anything else that you'd like to mention
Peter before we wrap up
no other than just to to really thank
people I think that
there's a lot of noise out there in the
world today and I think that anyone
who's going to buy this book and devote
the time to read it or listen to it on
the audiobook
it's this is not a two crapper right
this is not a book you're going to read
on the toilet in in taking two craps so
I I just don't want to thank you oh I
think of all books as how many craps
every book is like it's a four crapper
that's a two crap
so it's an amazing honor little things
I've been doing for the book prep that
would have ordinarily annoyed me to no
end
haven't annoyed me at all because I'm
realizing that it is sort of a special
thing that you have a relationship with
someone you're not necessarily meeting
but
they're doing something that is giving
of themselves which is taking the time
to read this thing
and in exchange you're giving them
something that's that's you know
hopefully valuable so anyway thank you
for having me on the show Tim and thanks
for
people who are gonna maybe go out and
get this thing
all right guys it's no two crapper
that's my quote on the back of the book
you'll find it featured prominently on
Amazon
and uh Peter Peter congratulations man I
know this has been a long time coming
I'm excited for you I am even more
excited for the people who will read
this and hopefully derive from it some
clarity and focus amidst and
overwhelming amount of noise and
[__] out there
so I do see this as a very strong signal
in a sea of noise so I encourage people
to check it out outlive the science and
art of longevity
Dr Peter attia
nice to see you man and to be continued
in person soon maybe we'll have those
two drinks a piece with some red wine
and some nice selects of access deer
from your freezer and
best of luck with the launch man thanks
for making the time thanks man
appreciate it thank you so much